[Music]
sand is everywhere we use 40 to 50
billion tons of sand and gravel around
the world every year 40 to 50 billion
tons it's a fundamental resource to
construction and construction is one of
our biggest industries it's a massive
amount but sand is a finite resource now
we're facing a growing problem it's not
an infinite resource it is running out
and once we put it into buildings it's
actually really difficult to get back
out there's been a decade of
conversation around a sand crisis as the
world runs out of sand researchers say
something needs to change from the way
we build our cities to the way we
destroy them
to explore what can be done Nature has
brought three sculptors to academics and
17 tons of sand to this recycling plant
in London
this is a story that starts off with a
grain of sand and reaches around the
world impacting Global carbon emissions
and the economics of an enormous
industry
in this film we're going to ask a
question could the solution to the sand
crisis be to start thinking circularly
[Music]
if you're looking for sand look out for
concrete and you know what that looks
like you think about the buildings The
Columns and the blocks that make up our
buildings so there's sand in there about
30 of concrete is sand Jacqueline
glass's research focuses on transforming
the construction industry including
making better use of the precious
materials like sand that make up our
cities
but not all sand is created equal in
fact particles of buildings and have
very particular properties so they look
like triangles or squares they've got
nice little pointy bits to them because
that helps us bring them all together
and get them to stick together properly
this is what's sand made by water
erosion looks like unfortunately that
doesn't apply to the sound found in
abundance in deserts around the world
and that's quite different because
that's formed by the wind blowing so it
makes these very smooth rounded little
particles and they just don't come
together as well so we can't use the
desert sand for construction so getting
the right kind of sand is harder than
you might think and often it means
disturbing local ecosystems we're taking
sand we're mining it or we're extracting
it from say rivers or beaches along the
coast
and it affects nature it affects animal
life it affects water flows and yet
because sand is in such high demand
illegal mining operations are Rife and
that sometimes involves forced labor and
slavery
so the extraction of sand
can lead to social problems locally as
well as Environmental
as well as concrete this sand is used to
make building materials like cement
bricks mortar and tarmac it's everywhere
from the foundations of buildings right
up to the top of the tallest skyscrapers
but while a sand castle can be turned
back into its original building material
and remade over and over again the same
isn't always true for the sand used in
buildings once we put it into buildings
it's actually really difficult to get
back out and reuse Fiona Charlie is an
expert on circular business modeling
working with different Industries to
think about the resources that they're
using reusing and potentially wasting
we tend to focus on the design of
buildings and the use of buildings once
they're constructed but give little
thought to what happens afterwards
demolition process can we reuse the
valuable materials and resources that
are in buildings researchers like Fiona
are arguing that there needs to be a
change in the whole economic model for
construction within our current linear
economy materials and products flow from
the mining company through to the
manufacturers to the retailers and then
to the end users and typically end up in
landfill however there's lots that we
can do to retain that value and loop it
back into our system thinking about
looping and maintaining the value of
materials like sand across their whole
life is part of an idea known as the
circular economy so the sector economy
actually it's it's not that
revolutionary it's just taking the core
components of our linear economy and
rearranging them so actually that we're
sharing that value we're feeding that
value back into the system and products
and materials are inherently designed to
go round and round and be used as many
times as possible by circulating
materials back into the industry there's
less waste and that reduces the need to
extract new materials something
particularly relevant to sand and
Construction in the UK the construction
and demolition industry produces well
over a hundred million tons of waste a
year
29 million tons of that goes to landfill
which does mean we're recovering and
reusing recycling quite a lot recycling
concrete like they do at this plant is
an important part of making construction
more sustainable but it's not always the
most efficient option available that
recycling process is hugely energy and
resource intensive and it means breaking
that product down into its component
parts or even destroying the materials
what happens is kind of what you can see
here
we demolished the building we take it
apart and we break it up and it means
that those components that were designed
with such care will never get that value
back from these materials ever again we
can only use them in a lower grade
application because we now don't know
what they're capable of the circular
economy provides alternatives to
recycling waste materials if we go back
to the design process we can understand
why there's waste there in the first
place it's because we're thinking in
rather a linear way and we're almost
expecting ways to happen so people are
really interested in design for
deconstruction designed for disassembly
one alternative to recycling is
buildings with components that can
simply be reused as they are so for
example with precast concrete we could
remove a whole piece of a building
whether it's a floor beam or a column
and we could reuse it in its entirety
because it's been designed to be taken
apart and also we know exactly what it
was designed to do in the first place so
we can reuse that entire piece with
confidence even more efficient than
reusing components is reusing entire
buildings so for example the University
of Cambridge the center for a
sustainability leadership its new
building was a telephone exchange so
they've kept almost the whole building
intact from previously they've brought
in a whole reception desk which was
destined for waste it was destined for
landfill in fact simply extending the
lifespan of a building while it's in use
is a key part of the circular economy
the most efficient way that we can
retain the value that's Within products
is at the use phase the user can
maintain and look after their product
themselves they can get them refurbished
and upgraded and then once the part or
the product has come to the end of its
life with one user it actually can be
shared between multiple users so
sometimes that could mean considering
alternatives to Knocking a building down
and starting again the in-use phase of a
building is actually often overlooked
but there's huge potential there and
this is again about looking forward when
you're designing because you can think
about how can I help its future
occupants or its future owners to adapt
the building rather than having to
demolish it so for example one of the
older buildings at Canary Wharf which
was built in 1991
the piles and these are the concrete
feet that hold a building up they are
quite deep actually they can take more
building on top and what they've been
able to do is they've been able to keep
that building intact and make it bigger
because those piles can take extra
weight
so that building now has a longer life
than might have been expected because
it's been able to be adapted and
extended the circular economy isn't a
revolutionary idea but it's one that
could change the way we think about
sustainability it's only really in the
last 10 to 12 years that the term sexual
economy has been used much more
frequently and actually I think it's a
fantastic framework for businesses to
understand that actually sustainability
doesn't just have to be about reduction
and Recycling and minimizing but
actually the sexual economy is about
creating new Revenue new profit new
value and about Innovation and
Entrepreneurship but that's not all the
production of concrete and cement
accounts for something like four to
eight percent of global carbon dioxide
emissions that's more than the output of
most countries and a circular
construction model could drastically
reduce those emissions the sector
economy is a key way of helping us to
achieve our 2050 climate goals and to
help tackle climate change and it really
needs to be introduced as core strategy
both in our industrial strategy but also
our climate policies to make sure that
we have the right legislation in place
to help us to create this shift
according to Fiona cooperation between
government and Industry will be key and
Academia too has a role to play at the
moment the sector economy has been
largely industry-led businesses are
innovating particularly small businesses
and entrepreneurs and to a certain
extent Academia is still catching up
there's a real emphasis on on Academia
to provide the underpinning evidence
base to back up a lot of decisions that
we'll need to be making to implement
sector economy and also collaboration
between Academia industry and policy is
going to be essential because this shift
we need to do at scale we can't just
look at independent parts of our enemy
or particular materials or particular
businesses we need to all be joined up
to be doing this together
I've always been passionate passionate
about the environment and sustainability
and even making small interventions into
the way we build
changing even one architect's decision
about the way they build and the
materials they choose can have a real
carbon benefit
so if I can influence even one person to
think a little bit differently
that's what's important to me
[Music]
I love concrete you can't use that
though a bit biased really
um